now if you asked me to name the seven
dorms that might be trickier then sleepy
dopey happy doc Nashville Graham Dumb
and Dumber I'm excited
dizzy I live for everything Disney my
18th birthday was Princess Tiana thing
yeah we actually both served as princess
party performers for children's company
for a while so we had to learn a lot of
details or at least be able to live
really well to children my favorite
movie is smart house Wow we have a very
different Disney bringing I am very
Disney Princesses we've seen every
single Disney movie multiple times in
the sword in the stone
what was the sword stuck in it's either
a a stone or an anvil a stone because it
says sword in the stone you want to say
stone but it's not it's an I remember in
a man but I think I remember in Disney
World - I'm not gonna I'm not going to
stop I'm going with the says a stone or
an anvil can't we not agree on it and
this be this fall if it's wrong when we
when said it was an end I think there's
an anvil okay so I'm I'm gonna go
anthalie feel an anvil sure okay okay
seems weird cuz it's the name of the
movie you know let's do it then I'm
going all-in
anvil look that's what we did yeah okay
great
all right so far one and one feeling no
just absolutely confident we're gonna
nail this which is a correct line in the
Evil Queen says and Snow White mirror
mirror on the wall who is the fairest of
them all magic mirror on the wall who is
the fairest one of them all magic mirror
on the wall I know this one
me too right yeah because everyone
quotes the first one they always say
Marilyn well first of them all but no
that's not it it's actually magic mirror
on the wall and it's rude that they
don't address him properly
on it cuz I remember being in there and
be like wait it's not Mirror Mirror like
in Star Wars when they're everyone
always like Luke I am your father but
that's not the actual line this is the
same thing so we're going to now 101
Dalmatians
what is this character's name and we
know it is Cruella De Vil correct now
it's a spelling test I'm going with the
D right with that de separate and you
know just because I think she's a she's
a badass and that's a bad that's why you
spell it
yeah I agree but I'm gonna go with
because I believe this was based in
France mmm and that is the way they
would tradition is builder name I think
that it's the one where de Ville is all
one word no I don't know at all well I
told you I don't think it's right ok
we're going with the a choice duh yes
[Applause]
feeling very cocky now ready okay we're
going back to jungle book times now
which of these is the actual scene in
the jungle book okay oh they look the
exact same
no she doesn't have the bra just
technically speaking give you cut the
size I think it's easier to add a
coconut bra than to take it away oh yeah
I'm gonna say yes the one with no sans
bra yeah I've seen this one a long time
ago but I'm not gonna remember they had
coconuts or not
so you said go in the bra yeah cuz I
have a lovely bunch of coconuts diddly
diddly dum isn't that I've got a lovely
bunch of coconuts dvbe dude we're gonna
go with the coconut oil coconut that
song was not right the jungle book light
no one is my DGP you know okay which of
the following is the correct lyric no no
I know this is bad the first one is
hi-ho hi-ho it's off to work we go which
is right what feels right but the second
choice is heigh-ho heigh-ho it's
home from work we go buzz me you I love
y'all but I ain't singing no song coming
in to work I'm going with it's home from
work we go because I'm for sure singing
some songs on my way home in both beds
alright melodically both good this snow
white takes me down I'm so angry I say
me to go with the one that our memory is
telling us is that right yes yeah that
makes sense going to work going from
work I'm singing going from work gonna
go from work that's how I would be wrong
it's home from work home from work we go
yes okay I don't know I don't feel good
about it okay no we do it okay we could
do it
yeah I was really concerned about that
well I want to stop hmm well I mean I
was right so does Mickey have a tell in
Steamboat Willie oh I know the presence
of the Frog no clue so go ahead Oh
because Mickey doesn't have a tail now
but I right from what I'm remembering
cuz this plays in the beginning of the
old well it plays in the intro now to
the new Disney movie yeah and he's like
spinning the wheel yeah I think he has a
tail because I believe it's doing
something in the background that I was
thinking no I mean you're so confident
which I was so confident but then like I
looked at the tail rocks like oh man I
think I remember seeing away and sale
but then I'm looking at I'm like no I'm
pretty sure he got to make it booties no
you holding it close I think you got a
tail I said you have to fail too but
it's really a mouse um I think my
muscles got tails right I don't know I
never keep a mouse on got Mouse's this
bad okay look close no it's the tail is
there are you sure believe me
just believe me I'm three minutes older
I know three minute more than huge about
this I'm gonna say yes he had a tail I'm
gonna I'm gonna say yes II I tell - oh
man let's do it me thinking reversely so
the tail there's a tail anyway
yes let's get this one what hat work
what hats where the Tweedles wearing an
alice in the weather land yeah this was
not me Alice in the Wonderland
I ain't seen none of that okay so they
either had flags or propellers I only
know this because when I would watch it
I'd be like are they gonna fly away and
that was the one with the little
spinning hats
I think it's flat okay alright do it
even better than expected okay we really
should end now or we all good I think
Alice in Wonderland are you watching no
they had the little spinny thingies the
real questionwhat Alice in Wonderland
are you watching
all around the subject of Alice in
Wonderland which of these is the correct
Cheshire Cat quote most everyone is mad
here we're all mad here Oh
most everyone is mad here we're all mad
here I want to go we're all mad here
because like who says most everyone here
is mad I'm gonna go with this one so if
it's wrong he finally has a strike wait
I could go with that most everyone is
mad here yeah okay yeah I agree
okay okay okay okay
hey awesome first off everybody has a
bad day I was voting for us to pick that
L so you can get one wrong I never met
someone so happy to lose
how many more honest honestly so pleased
with that we do not watch Alice in
Wonderland so can you see Cinderella's
ears in the movie no no no that is like
negative she's like nope do that yeah I
feel good about nice Wow
Disney's too lazy to make years I guess
yeah because then you have to do
earrings and that's more CGI and like
Cinderella
like what the finally that means it's
the last one okay
this is a big one if we mess up now it's
all been for nothing which of these
Disney castles is correct Walt Disney
Pictures Walt Disney Pictures no so you
see how the castle shorter on this end I
know um I'm gonna go with the one on the
left but I don't think it's that bad I
don't think it's that wide either too
even okay oh it's just I was weird
oh so you think I know I support your
decision teammate she's real supportive
right now let's see okay so I think it's
the one and not symmetric the
asymmetrical one yeah that's I think two
back on the winners column Leslie yeah
that is a hundred percent ladies and
gentlemen this is there ain't no strings
on you whoa nobody is brainwashed you
with false Disney memories you know
Disney trivia like it's your job it was
for a while actually and do you remember
everything with eerily accurate details
yes that's right
you swore it better than 91 percent of
Whitacre oh so we didn't get a 91
percent we just score better than 91
percent of people I went there 91
percent back I did I feel very glad that
all of the hours we've spent watching
these things have actually paid off it
says there ain't no strings on you do
you know that's from Pinocchio go hey
you've been off it could be like be the
life I think you were smart house
actually it was there one of those long
it's that girl's house let me finish
reading this it says well that was also
Ravens all right we never knew we were
coming to this point you know it was all
for this and and you're welcome yeah
[Music]